hi guys sci-fi recapped here before we
start morning
spoilers ahead today i'm gonna explain a
unique and heartwarming thriller science
fiction film called monolith
set in the near future there's an
advertisement promoting monolith this
car is awarded as the safest car in the
world due to its very advanced
technology such as an anti-roll sensor
everything can be controlled from inside
the car or from an ai connected gadget
called lilith
sandra is a woman who is driving the
monolith with her little son david she
wants to go to her mother-in-law's house
but her husband doesn't come because
he's busy working as a pilot as can be
seen the car is very sophisticated that
lilith can detect the weight of every
passenger inside
during her trip sandra intentionally
calls her husband and finds out that her
husband carl is at a hotel not far from
the central airport sandra who begins to
suspect him only can be silent moreover
she has to take care of her fussy child
by giving him a cell phone so he can be
quiet she decides to take a short break
at a gas station with a convenience
store next to it she buys some stuff for
herself and david when she wants to pay
for the groceries a man wants to steal
her car
with ease she could overcome this
through lilith from her cell phone
however she just realizes and panics
that david has disappeared
it turns out he is with a group of women
who want to play with him because he's
very cute
enraged sandra immediately takes him to
the car and activates the vault mode to
avoid any kind of interference from
outside
then she continues her journey
feeling bored she calls her friend jessa
who is also in a hotel near the airport
unintentionally she makes sandra realize
that she is in the same hotel with carl
in other words she's having an affair
with her friend's husband
sandra who knows about this immediately
calls carl but unfortunately he doesn't
pick up
she feels very disappointed with him and
decides to divert the trip to los
angeles where the hotel is located on
her way lilith informs her that there
has been an accident on the highway so
it can slow down her journey
finally it advises her to take an
off-road route for a shortcut the route
is very dark and deserted leading her to
only see an electric substation on the
side of the road
shortly after she lights a cigarette to
relax but that causes lilith to initiate
the car's smoke alarm
as a result the car accidentally hits a
wild deer
she gives her tearful son her cell phone
to distract him before she checks what
was going on
then she screams in panic because the
deer is not completely dead and she
doesn't know what to do next
while she is outside the car david is
playing with the app for monolith which
has been installed on sandra's phone he
accidentally activates the vault mode
locks and seals the whole car completely
and prevents sandra from entering an
overly panic sandra teaches her son to
open the car's door but instead startles
him and also drops the phone under the
seat
she starts looking for different ways to
open the car she even tries to break the
window using a stone but still her
effort remains in vain
apparently she's trying to find help at
a nearby electric substation which she
has seen before
initially she has to climb the gate and
finds no one in there but luckily she
finds a flashlight and a wrench to break
the window again
outside from there she meets a wild
coyote making her run back and climb on
the roof of the car
then she tries to break the windshield
using the wrench but it still doesn't
work
desperately she sleeps on the roof of
the car while accompanying david for the
night
after a night full of nightmares she
sees david is trapped in his child
safety seat he is struggling to breathe
and starts to lose consciousness while
the temperature of the car rises as the
air conditioning is switched off
sandra begins to wander around the
desert near the monolith car
fortunately she finds a stream of water
to drink
not far from there she also finds an
abandoned plane at a deserted airport
of course no one is there
then she decides to burn some tires
using liquor from the plane's minibar to
form a distressed signal and lastly she
also finds an empty bottle
she fills the bottle with river water
for her son
then she returns to the monolith and
douses the car with the water she found
before hoping to lower the temperature
in the car
after a while she notices that david is
unconscious even though he slightly
moves his hand
she begins to lose hope when she notices
that the coyote is back
using the wrench found at the electrical
station she tries to tackle the coyote
which ends up biting her ankle
sandra finally understands that the
coyote wants the carcass of the deer but
as soon as it starts to feed the
monolith car starts moving down the hill
sandra tries her best to stop the car
using a nearby stone
soon she has a brilliant idea
first she intimidates the coyote making
it runs away
then she decides to push the car further
away from the hill using the wrench to
break the stone the monolith with david
in it falls off the hill as the
technology detects the gravitational
pressure at that position making it
lands perfectly with that idea the doors
eventually opened and allow sandra to
recover the poor david apparently dying
at the same time the stunning monolith
automatically reactivates the system so
it can be used as before
sandra reluctantly relies on lilith to
get out from the hole they seem to be in
opting for off-road mode and freeing
herself and her son
arriving in a hospital she sees david
awakes for the first time little david
calls her mom because during the movie
he always called her sandra this movie
shows that a great mother always
sacrifices everything for her child
subscribe to watch more videos like this
turn on notifications and leave a like
to help the channel out thank you for
watching
[Music]